welcome to the man of recaps this is
severance season one meet mark scott who
works at the megacorporation lumen
industries and he's had an exciting new
procedure called severance which splits
your memories between your work and home
life this means from his perspective he
clocks in and goes down the elevator
then it's immediately five o'clock
quitting time sounds amazing but this
means for his work persona it's the
opposite he never actually gets to leave
the office which is basically hell the
innies as they're called make the best
of things enjoy some nice co-worker
camaraderie but today there's a huge
shake up as mark finds out his best
friend in here petey quit without notice
so mark will never see him again but
this means mark is the new department
head so he's going to do his best and
his first job is to train petey's
replacement a new girl helly r
initiation is terrifying and
disorienting as you wake up on this
conference table with no memory of who
you are as mark reads the corporate
script about severance heli rightfully
freaks out and tries to escape but it's
like look you're not a prisoner here of
course you can leave but every time she
walks out she walks right back in
because her audi is like what are you
doing get back to work the direct
supervisor is mr milchik who is not
severed and is kind of like their
babysitter to celebrate helly's first
day they get the super exciting melon
bar and other fun team building
activities but telly is not having it
she writes herself a note that she wants
to quit but the elevator sensors pick it
up they've got a strict no notes policy
of course you can send your audi a
resonation request through the proper
channels but they're always denied
mark's like look you make the best of it
in here their one co-worker dylan lives
for the silly perks you get for hitting
your quotas while irving their older
co-worker has a religious-like reverence
for lumen and their founder keir egan
for mark's part he just tries to keep a
positive attitude and assumes the work
they're doing is important now what are
they doing their department is macro
data refinement and they're just sorting
unintelligible random numbers but when
you look at them for a while groups of
numbers evoke different emotions like
group 1 numbers are scary it sounds
ridiculous until you see it for yourself
it's clearly encrypted somehow so they
have no idea what they're sorting dylan
thinks they're clearing the sea of
killer eels but it's probably not that
now mark's outside life is not that
exciting his wife died in a car crash a
few years back and he's mostly just
depressed he has a funny pregnant sister
though who he loves and her husband is a
hilariously insufferable
pseudo-intellectual but the big shake-up
comes when he gets a visit from his work
friend petey he's gone through
reintegration to undo his severance and
it's like look it's bad down there and
lumen's up to no good i'm caught up in a
corporate conspiracy they're out to kill
me mark's like look man i don't know you
if we're best friends i guess you can
crash here for a while but i don't want
to get involved but he's already
involved because his nice old lady
neighbor mrs selvig is his boss mrs
cobell and yeah she's got a key to his
house and like snoops around to keep
tabs on him she doesn't find pd but
reintegration is rough eventually he
wanders off and dies of a brain aneurysm
and someone keeps calling pd's phone but
mark ignores it for now inside hely
refuses to work she keeps trying to find
ways to tell her audi she quits
eventually she causes enough trouble
she's punished with a timeout in the
break room she's forced to read this
weirdly religious apology over and over
again a thousand times until she means
it but she's not broken she's madder
than ever takes her fingers hostage and
demands to make a video telling her audi
how awful it is here but her audi sends
her back down with a response video look
you don't get to make the decisions
you're not a real person not a real
person am i well hell is going to show
her she tries to hang herself in the
elevator so her audi wakes up with a
nasty surprise they're able to save her
in time though she survives and even
after that her audi still sends her back
in this really troubles mark he drops
the professional persona and tries to
connect with heli person to person and
there's been a couple of other big
shake-ups mark found that petey was
trying to map the hallways very much
against the rules mark's brother-in-law
left him a copy of his new book and
lumen confiscated it to check for
messages but they accidentally left it
out where the severed workers found it
and they've never seen any book except
the company handbook the book is
hilariously bad pretentious self-help
dribble but to these innies who have
never read anything before it blows
their minds another big shake-up comes
when macro data bumps into another
department yes that's christopher walken
bert g of optics and design they're in
charge of deciding where to hang the
weirdly religious corporate art but
coincidentally irving bumped into him
earlier and these two bonded over their
love of art and cure egan these two
continue to visit and get an office
flirtation going yes it's a super cute
old dude romance dylan doesn't trust o
and d though there's rumors that years
ago they attacked macro data but turns
out o d heard rumors macro data attacked
them seems like management's playing
them against each other heli's being
monitored now by their wellness director
miss casey who they sometimes meet with
for these corporate scripted wellness
sessions a hug is available upon request
but mark spills some coffee on her
notebook to get her out of there for a
while and he takes heli on a real walk
to talk about things it's like look i'm
with you now this place is messed up so
they start to really bond but wait where
are they now they've wandered farther
than ever before through the labyrinth
of indistinguishable hallways and they
find another department they didn't know
existed where it's just this guy raising
baby goats
what is going on here so macro data
refinement bands together decides they
need to befriend optics and design who
turns out have a bunch of people back
here 3d printing random objects but
management's not having this their
hallway privileges are revoked and bert
g is forced into retirement their
blossoming love story tragically cut
short now their boss mrs cobell is a
strange character who's a full devotee
of the kir-egan religion and it's
unclear why she has such a keen interest
in mark's life but she's not the top
boss she still reports to the board of
directors who only speak to her through
this proxy and on the intercom where
they never say anything and she's not
afraid to get her hands dirty goes to
petey's funeral to retrieve his
severance chip where yeah they find he
was reintegrated it wasn't supposed to
be possible mark finally decides to pick
up petey's phone and meets the lumen
doctor who now decided severance is evil
and is working against him but just then
lumen security tracks him down too and
she's gotta kill this guy what's mark
gotten into she gives mark his key card
take it to work your innie will know
what to do and there's another big
development when dylan g is woken up
outside the office they didn't know this
was possible it's called the overtime
contingency just for emergencies the
emergency is while hanging out in o d
dylan grabbed this like random
self-defense card and pocketed it mr
milchik's like look you have no idea how
sensitive that is where did you hide it
it's like no it's just back at the
office but then they're interrupted by
dylan's son it's only for a second but
now it's changed his life so they're all
now being more closely supervised than
ever but there's still time for some
corporate fun because helyar hits 75
which has earned her an mde a music
dance experience she chooses defiant
jazz and it's an awesome dance party the
most fun you ever have in here but
dylan's still thinking about his son he
snaps an attacks mill chick the mde is
cancelled he fills them all in about the
overtime contingency and it's like look
we can use this to tell people outside
we're prisoners in here and mark has no
idea how his audi got it but he's got
the security key card it's time for a
revolution first step of the plan though
they have to work hard to hit their
quota and earn the much coveted egg bar
and tonight's the big night so as
they're saying goodbye oh helly and mark
start smooching yeah office romance now
because the hit quota dillon g as the
top refiner gets to stay late for the
even more coveted waffle party in the
replica cure mansion they have here and
turns out there's a secret second part
to the waffle party you get to watch a
super weird sexy dance but dylan dips
out he's on a mission goes to the
security office and activates the
overtime contingency and so are innies
wake up in the outside world mark finds
himself at a bit of a party in fact it's
a reading of his favorite book and turns
out the genius authors his own
brother-in-law wow my life's amazing
irving finds out he's a painter but he's
been compulsively painting the same
thing over and over again this scary
dark hallway that's not the break room
hallway what is it well turns out miss
casey was just fired and sent to a
different elevator not the one that goes
up but one that goes further down what
is going on here and why does irving
remember it heli finds herself at a
fancy party and learns that she is
helena egan and this whole party's about
her yes her working there was all for
pro-severance propaganda she briefly
meets her father the current woman ceo
and they're really trying to make
severance a bigger thing in fact earlier
when mark's sister went on a birthing
retreat she made friends with another
pregnant woman and when she ran into her
later absolutely didn't remember her her
husband's a pro severance senator and it
seems like she severed herself to avoid
the pain of giving birth but mark now
runs into a big problem their boss mrs
cobell is at this party yeah as mark's
nice neighbor mrs selvig she's been the
nice baby helper for his sister but any
mark doesn't know that and calls her mrs
cobell oh the jig is up actually the
board had just fired her that day but
she's ready to get her job back and stop
this any rebellion but mark succeeds on
his mission tells his sister everything
you go to expose to the world how bad it
is down there meanwhile irving finds out
he's out he's been researching severance
in fact he's got a map with a bunch of
severed employees on it including bert g
he rushes over there only to find he is
happily married but he's knocking on the
door anyway but hell he's got the
biggest stage she's the keynote speaker
and reveals she's the innie and my
life's a living hell but now mark makes
an epic discovery his dead wife is miss
casey it's a race against time as he
runs out there she's alive and just then
milchik tackles dylan the link is cut
and that's where season one comes to an
end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]